[Music]
because of who you are there will always
be forces gathering against evil
disguised as a friend slipping past you
as a stranger they are everywhere
if you choose to continue whereas you
are
know that you risk everything it's time
a child touched by fire destined to be
our greatest warrior
you are a living weapon drive all other
thoughts out of your mind exists
[Music]
this is my purpose
hey youtubers it's Charlie finally got
that Iron Fist trailer let's break it
down I've also got some news about
Punisher and defenders oh my god
probably the best part of this is just
seeing his fists light up with Qi as he
gets ready to use his powers so that
that's his superpower he's able to
harness his Chi so if you've seen like
the cartoons or you seen the comics when
his fists are on fire that's the energy
that he's harnessing so there were four
clips that they showed off at New York
Comic Con most of it shows up in this
trailer here with Danny ran first coming
back to New York kind of looking like a
hobo no shoes on seeing Rand industries
which is kind of like the defenders
version of Stark Industries Danny Rand
is a billionaire just like Tony Stark so
they won't have any problems getting new
gear but as the monks voice over in the
trailer implies because of who you are
people will always be coming after you
trying to take what you have so that's
where you get into Meechum characters so
it like on the Danny ran side of this
you have the Meacham's sort of like the
human villains then you have the hand on
the other side of this because in one of
the clips he's talking to Harold Meacham
who's kind of like the kingpin he's
played by David when I'm here
he's one of the biggest villains of the
series but when Danny ran is having this
conversation with them he says that iron
fist is the mortal enemy of the hand
these two are the Meacham siblings they
might change the comics a little bit and
make them the son and daughter of Harold
Meacham but you have like the Meacham
family you have the Rand family Danny is
an orphan now just because his parents
were killed in that plane crash even if
you haven't seen the comics they show
some of the older footage in this too
but the cool thing here is is that
Harold Meacham knows about iron fist
stuff he knows about the capital cities
of heaven and says I understand you were
taken in by some monks on the order of
crane mother who is confirmed to be
Madame Gao as we thought previously
during daredevil they always kind of
back-and-forth about that like crane
mother always seemed like she was gonna
show up during iron fist and now it's
just confirmed but it but it seems like
the Meacham's have since taken over RAND
Corporation so there's
the revenge aspect like Harold Meacham
is responsible for his family's death
but he also gets tied up in this larger
conflict with the hand which is kind of
our crossover point with the other
Netflix series now I don't they didn't
really get into like hands stuff when we
did Luke Cage but think daredevil season
2 in kind of the crossover with kingpin
crane mother in the other people that
were part of that crime syndicate so
defenders will make that a little bit
more clear and they did confirm that
Sigourney Weaver is the big bad of
defenders they didn't say who she's
playing though but iearnt best the next
most cool thing about this is Colleen
wing she is definitely going to be my
new favorite female character inside the
Netflix universe even more than Elektra
just based on this footage
she headbutts a dude's fist as he's
trying to punch her two dudes in a cage
match just going crazy so she's kind of
like a Claire temple misty Knight type
figure who will help Danny Rand she's
like she's one of the good characters so
Claire temple also confirmed to be
showing up in iron fist they brought
rosario Dawson on stage during the panel
and if you've seen the end of Luke Cage
then you'll know like the point of
crossover there's a really small moment
that explains the connection between
Colleen wing and Claire temple but they
did say the Claire temple would get to
throw down during iron fist because
she's been training a little bit so even
if you haven't read the comics or seen
any of the cartoons let me know what you
think about the iron fist visual-effects
I think it's actually pretty good like
it's not too outlandish and it looks
more in keeping with the power levels of
say like Luke Cage in the other
defenders like iron fist is super
powerful but you want to have a certain
amount of parody between the defenders
characters in their power levels and
abilities so like Daredevils fighting
style for instance looks very similar to
iron fist but because iron fist is
full-blown kung-fu he's just a little
more graceful so when it comes to
strength
he's also when you know when he's like
fully charged with his Chi is about Luke
Cage level strength I would say a little
more powerful than that but he actually
has to like harness it it's not like an
always-on kind of ability like Luke Cage
has like Luke Cage is kind of like a
walking tank and his tough skin is like
a passive ability he doesn't need to
activate it iron fist does so you'd have
to catch him unawares in order to get
the upper hand
that it looks badass it's coming out
March 17th so of course I'll be doing
videos for it when it gets here we'll
probably see a whole bunch more trailers
early next year as they start ramping up
and they're getting ready to shoot
defenders next month they've already
started shooting The Punisher but I'll
do like a separate video for Punisher
stuff but they have started like they
literally just started shooting Punisher
this week which is way earlier than I
thought it was gonna be so big if but if
they can finish filming by really really
early next year then they might be able
to get the Punisher series out by the
very end of next year so big if they're
just depends on how fast they're able to
get through it but I already did that
Netflix and chill video so I'll post a
link to that at the end of this so you
can listen to like the other defenders
characters talk about the timelines when
they're gonna be meeting up so get hype
it's gonna be awesome and just because
I'm so happy I'm gonna start a new round
of the Marvel giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so what's gonna
happen next is I have a new flash video
that I'm almost done with and then I'm
gonna post The Walking Dead Season 7
panel there's also supposed to be some
new Walking Dead footage that's still a
few weeks away from premiering so I'll
probably do a video for that on Monday
so just so much New York Comic Con stuff
dropping I'll try to stay on top of all
of it there's gonna be some more Jon
Bernthal punisher stuff tomorrow and
i'll try to add it to any punisher
videos that i make in the next couple of
days so get hype what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
defenders netflix and chill' video and
you can click here for the justice
league behind the scenes video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight